alicia for more details on the growing
crisis at our southern border let's turn
to former acting homeland security
secretary under president trump and
america first policy institute's center
for homeland security and immigration
chairman chad wolfe chad thank you for
taking time on a saturday picking up on
casey's great reporting down there i can
tell you he called it an active night it
is not only active it is even more
active than last year in the last 24
hours chad there are 1
414 illegal crossing encounters in just
that sector alone it's up 161
percent you can see our live drone
flying over la jolla in that rgv sector
so my question to you sir will
reinstating remain in mexico help get
this under control
well it will certainly help but it won't
help overnight this is going to be a
sustained program that they need to
continue to implement month after month
after month and what we know and what
we've seen the bite administration say
is they don't believe in the program
that they're only doing this because a
court has ordered them to implement this
and as soon as they get relief from the
court they are going to end the program
so there's a real messaging problem here
part of the mpp is not only the policy
but it's the message that it sends and
if you are telling migrants and you're
telling the cartels that we really don't
believe in this program and we're going
to end it as soon as we get the chance
to it's really not going to have the
effect that you need to at the end of
the day so i think they've got some real
challenges in re-implementing the
migrant protection protocols they've
also changed a number of the program
features and we're going to have to see
if if that's you know really gets it to
its full potential on whether those
become loopholes in the program itself
so i think there's a lot to
really examine and see how they do
implementing the program over the next
uh several months oh you you are very
correct sir in the changes and the devil
in the details in fact we can show you a
quick map it's seven ports of entry that
they're going to do it two are in
california in san diego calexico you've
got nogales and arizona and then of
course in texas el paso laredo eagle
pass
brownsville texas but
we're not
talking chad about how much impact it
has on the mexican side those northern
mexican cities tijuana juarez matamoros
it's going to overflow already over
crowded situation there
well absolutely certainly in the
beginning and again i would say you know
to the bite administration welcome to
the game this is what border enforcement
looks like i'm not sure where they've
been for the past 10 to 11 months this
is what they should have been doing from
day one instead of canceling the program
and then going through all these
different machinations to try to restart
it the government of mexico if you go
back to the trump administration when we
negotiated mpp at the end of the day
they like this program because if it's a
sustained program they saw that the
illegal migration through mexico was
reduced and that helps not only their
infrastructure and their facilities and
the services that they have to render
these migrants so over the long term
they like it which is i assume why they
again agreed to
resume the program at the end of the day
but again i've got concerns when we talk
about
the new procedures of the mpp they are
now going to ask each mpp enrollee
whether they have a fear of returning to
mexico well guess what you're going to
see a higher and higher number of people
say yes
and as soon as they say yes i have a
fear of returning to mexico guess what
they're not enrolled in mpp so it's
these little changes that they're making
that that can really make or break the
program at the end of the day jed i want
to talk about the concerns at the border
over the spread of this new covet
variant omicron earlier this week dr
fauci was asked about testing at the
border here's what he said listen
what about people who don't take a plane
in just these border crossers coming in
in huge numbers that's a different issue
of somebody getting on a plane getting
checked looking at a passport we don't
have that there but we can get some
degree of mitigation is there something
to do to test these people somewhere
else no there is there is testing at the
border under certain circumstances
i've been to the border numerous times
and i have not seen the testing he
speaks of chad your reaction
well there's there's little to no
testing at the border i think you hear
the dhs secretary saying that we have a
policy to test people but that's very
different on whether they are actually
implementing the policy and he refuses
to say whether they're actually
implementing the policy so look i've
been around dr fauci in the trump
administration
numerous times he simply doesn't want to
deal with the the politics of trying to
test these individuals along the
southwest border and i think it's very
very important because we have
restrictions the biden administration
has imposed restrictions on individuals
choosing to come here into the country
legally
from overseas but if you come across the
border from some of those same countries
in africa and other places illegally
across the southwest border you don't
get tested you don't have a vaccine
mandate you don't have a quarantine
mandate and so i think their policy is
just out of touch with the american
people and the american people see the
hypocrisy of it
former acting dhs secretary chad wolfe
chad thank you for taking time
all right thank you